hi there steve kaufman today my subject
is the golden age of language learning
it suddenly dawned on me that we live in
the golden age of language learning now
things may improve
but uh compared to 50 years ago 30 years
ago or
hundreds of years ago
um and i'll give you some reasons why uh
i decided or i said there was a request
that i do videos in other languages so i
started doing that
now some languages it's easier for me
than in others so french is quite easy
spanish is not so easy why because i
have spoken an awful lot of french i
lived there for three years i studied
there i've read lots
spanish
i you know i would say when i first went
there
well i first went there in 1964 and i
hitchhiked around and i spoke a lot of
french and i was listening to truck
drivers and it's not french spanish
listening to truck drivers heard a lot
of spanish and that was kind of the
level of my spanish until about 15 or 20
years ago when i started trying to read
books and at first it was very difficult
and the more books i read the better i
got at it now i've read so many books in
spanish that i can read spanish almost
like english but i don't speak very
often like now i might speak once or
twice a year
so it's more difficult for me in spanish
so i say okay in order to make my do my
video in spanish i better kind of
refresh my spanish so what can i do
so i can download the ebook
for looking for some books to read i
find this di meken soy i've mentioned it
before i download it it's like 900 pages
great long book i got it on my kindle so
i i said i don't get a spanish book i
google i don't know how i hit upon this
book but it was recommended i'd buy it
it's on my kindle i've got it with me
i'm reading it then i say you know what
reading is not enough i need to be
hearing spanish so i go to audible.com
first of all i google spanish audiobooks
i find some sites where they have some
kind of very unpleasant to listen to uh
text-to-speech which is all right for a
word or a phrase but you can't listen to
a whole book in text to speech
but then i find that they have the
mckenzoy in spanish and audiobook at
audible.com which i discover also
belongs to amazon
okay i have an account there i buy the
audiobook immediately download it i put
an app on my iphone which is an
audible.com app so while i'm at it i
also buy another audiobook on the
history of the spanish civil war so
those two are plugged right into my
iphone wherever i go now i can switch
listen for a while to the history of the
spanish civil war i can listen to the
audio version of the book that i've
already read which yeah it's fun for a
while but after all i know the story so
it's kind of fun because you're
listening to some of the early parts of
the book where you didn't quite
understand who was doing what to whom
and now you hear it again so it kind of
helps fill in some of the blanks
but mostly i listen to this
audiobook on the history of the spanish
civil war which is just fascinating i
never really understood how within the
national side and the republican side
there are all these factions and
fighting and stuff going on and not to
mention the cruelty
uh you know of of the war and the number
of people who are killed and and so
forth and so on but it's just so easy to
do
uh i've got this on my iphone i you know
i'm i'm again sounds the way i have to
walk the dog in the afternoons i'm
listening to the stuff that i downloaded
off a site i'm listening to a novel i'm
listening to history
um
now
i look forward to making more videos
and so i can now you know audible you
can go in there select the language
japanese swedish subject history fiction
whatever i want german italian so i'm
going to be able to access
this material now you say yeah it costs
money well sure it costs money but
compared to a teacher
you know if i had had to learn romanian
or any of the language that i've learned
recently check you know if i had to
engage a teacher and go there once or
twice a week and then they decide okay
here's what we're going to study today
and i wouldn't get anywhere whereas this
way now granted you can't start from
scratch and start reading an audio book
on
on audible.com but there again as i've
mentioned before for romanian i just
wrote up sort of basic patterns of
commonly used you know concepts that we
like to express why because uh if
therefore
whatever it might be how when how many
200 phrases sentences i put it up
on on odesk uh please translate and
record back it comes okay it cost me a
bit of money but i put it up on link so
other people can enjoy it and i get
frequent comments from people thanking
me for having put those contents uh up
on a link up on link i i mean there's
more to it than that it's just there's
the italki's you can get on the internet
talk to other people if you want i don't
do a lot of that myself
um it's just just so easy i remember
some years ago i was approached by the
local community college to donate money
to their language lab and i said myself
why would you have a language lab
there's so much stuff available now
so
i'm just so much looking forward to
getting back into my swedish and
japanese and all these other languages
to prepare for my talk i don't know if
it improves the quality of my video but
it gives me motivation and remember
motivation is key it gives me a
motivation for doing it it's extremely
enjoyable
and so i really believe
that we live in the golden age of
language learning and in fact in many
ways we live in a golden age it's so
easy to get discouraged by all the bad
news that we hear but i mean when i
listened to the spanish civil war in the
second world war and went on them not
that that's a standard but
um
yeah there are issues
but i think that
we're solving them i'm quite convinced
that within 20 or 30 years the main
source of energy will be solar we'll
have massive batteries and we will have
resolved some of these issues that
surround energy and uh you know fossil
fuels and so forth and so on so i as
i've said many many times
i'm an optimist and i'm very happy to
live in the golden age of language
learning so that should encourage you to
go out there and do more language
learning bye for now